voulez-vous souper avec moi mais tu me
dérange pas mais dida voici les
premières images de l'émission la petite
vie c'était le 16 octobre 1993 chez moi
de retrouver jésus mais jouez pas aimé
25 ans plus tard marc messier se
souvient encore des réactions mitigées
au lendemain de la diffusion étalée au
dépanneur un supplément tu m'avais dit
écoutez monsieur messieurs je vous ai vu
hier soir en télévision d'institutions
loeb c'est vraiment ça vient d'un idiot
devriez être plus sélectif dans ce que
vous faites ça laisse grimper votre
carrière monsieur baissier la série a
finalement connu un succès monstre même
que le 20 mars 1995 l'épisode région
reçoit a battu des records
il a tiré plus de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs
tout le monde doit dire ce que c'était
les années bénigne
vraiment c'était tellement plaisant
personne parce que nous si quand le
quand les gens se sont mis à trouver ça
drôle c'est quand les quand tu fais
quelque chose puis que ça marche à ce
point ils doivent forcément ça crée des
liens sacrés des bouliers humain encore
aujourd'hui les rediffusions du samedi
soir saurait si radio canada télé attire
quelques 550 mille personnes mais je
pense la qualité du jeu grâce à cette
astuce optionnel le jeu des comédiens
cette vie ça a traversé le temps pis les
sujets sont encore actuelle c'est sur la
famille c'est des stéréotypes humains
aux archétypes humains des rapports
parents-enfants des rapports de cours
les autres projets de claude unis n'ont
jamais rencontré le succès qu'a eu la
petite vie malgré tout en question d'une
suite n'en peut plus de chats sont parce
que ces conduits gênante
mouais c'est comme je lé là toujours
aussi match ici à l'entrée d'un orage au
canada montréal
[Applaudissements]